welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm Grayson how big the first year
host guess what we have a beautiful
guest with us today it's very exciting
many MUA is with us he is a beauty guru
he's a makeup maven he he owns lunar
Beauty his makeup line he's hilarious he
has a crazy ass gym that he goes to
where many a story come from
he hates potato oh no I'm sorry egg on
my face
he loves potatoes and hates corn you'll
hear all about those fun things in this
episode of not too deep are you tired of
unpredictable hair color results will
discover color and Co the home hair
color personalized just for you by
L'Oreal with color and coat you'll get a
free consultation with an expert hair
stylist who will custom blend a salon
quality shade for your hair needs no
matter your hair goal you can do it use
promo code grace at color and code comm
for $10 off your first order mini hello
did you come from the gym no I did not
come from the gym are you still going to
the same gym there's a [ __ ] crazy
it's insane I was watching your gym
stories video this morning and I was
just wheeling like a little girl yes
like a little piglet it's bonkers to me
I mean what okay for people that don't
know what are I guess the like brief
synopsis of these situations well like
he said look at my gym there's like a
steam room yes and things happen in the
steam room when you're just not as
prepared like you're just like didn't
know was like I weigh the serum once and
there was literally like you cursed I
don't like mine sings crazy [ __ ] so I
literally like I walked
and it was totally fine I was everything
was normal and then do you like to see
like these like couple guys are like
kind of looking around like cruising and
I'm like oh my god like ill like I'm
really gonna tell like not you're
working out and they're over here like
full dicks out like jerking off and I'm
like am I gonna do literally like those
like maybe like six other guys in there
that's so and I was only with the towel
on I was like I have to escape open
escape room oh my I can't believe that
that happened what I can't believe that
cuz someone walked in and I kind of
liked a few like yes yes defuse the
energy of the situation didn't like
scold anyone but just like halted with
the momentum of what was happening it
was so lovely I'm like thank you so much
for walking in cuz I feel like I sort of
someone walks in like it just like calms
everything now cuz someone scares me
like a straight person like can you
imagine like a straight guy walking he's
like oh it's so bonkers but you still go
to the same gym yeah so gonna say J I
mean I still love like the gym I go to
it was just like a crazy situation that
I only happen to be like once okay and I
was like wow I mean but it happened to
you I'm like you know she goes down and
I'm like I can only this is actually
happening like I feel like the full
cruising moment well you also have a
saga potential romantic yes yes
okay where is the state of this
potentially romantic slightly awkwardly
clunky sock no it's very clunky it's
very awkward and clunky more than
romantic for sure like yesterday the to
date it was yesterday maybe I can't
remember no today's ago I had made I
made this video right in late night not
thinking he would watch it even though
he I know he knows who I am okay but I'm
like there's no way he's like a friend
that's like he just does it it's not my
demo let's just say that right so I'm
like okay it's totally fine he's not
gonna know last time I saw him
like yesterday two days ago I was
walking by and leaving
he's like hey let's go hi how are you
haven't seen him in like two weeks and
he's like got any fun videos planned and
I'm like he's like yeah of course and
he's like well I saw your video and I
was like right when I tell you guys like
my heart dropped to my [ __ ] it
literally was puckering was so sure I
was okay oh my god I was like no you did
it and sorry it was like no you did it
and he's like no I totally did and I was
like no you didn't and he's like he and
then I got so red and he was like
laughing he was like it that was so cute
such a cute video and I like hugged him
and he's like we stopped to hang out
soon and I'm like yeah sure whatever
we're not busy at the gym like well like
hang out and I walked away because I
literally like I couldn't stay there
longer cuz I my face was so red and hot
fire so I don't even like it right now
we're at a standstill okay again we're
always at a sin so it's just like a
weird thing but this stuff like that
change how much you tell personal
stories online it makes me like
apprehensive yes sure and I'm like okay
well if he's so honest did sell like
story times and I was scared that the
people that I tell story times about are
gonna see it right and like tell me
about it I'm like I don't want like
because the thing is also like when I'm
at the gym like I don't know when that
comes out to me no one like you like it
it's like what you're your own thing
right like and I'm like not glam so it's
literally just like no one really
recognized me chill the safe space safe
space so I go there thinking like no one
knows who I am and so like when I'm
doing things online I'm like scared that
they're gonna know exactly what I'm
talking about now I'm like the guy is
like quietly coming up with things to do
to hopefully get you to do a video what
if you did I would scream everything
like I never said his name and ever said
would you my go-to I've literally been
so like good about it it's a lot of mr.
a lot of mystery yeah and I feel like
I've been so good about it cuz I don't
wanna like say any names or anything
like that would be crazy you just want
to be elusive with it sure so I'm scared
incredible stories thank you and you've
never seen the middle-aged woman that
never yelled ever said I wish I did I
wish a [ __ ] would again be prepared I
would be more prepared so I'd be like oh
my god I literally didn't have any
comebacks for her at the time she was
really trying to fight me so I didn't
it's the endorphins it was crazy
yeah she was on her like full blown like
treadmill fantasy and I'm like okay well
see you but she was crazy oh I love it
okay let's take it back a little bit
well out a bit um so before you started
YouTube you worked at Sephora a Mac
right yes both of those places were Mac
I worked as a for a first uh-huh and
then I quit Safari to work at Mac and
what were those experiences like they
were grabbing Sephora was my first like
real makeup experience like real makeup
counter experience when I went in
learned about like skincare I learned
about makeup learn about application
learn about hygiene practices like I've
heard about so many things there yeah
about fragrance I mean so for has
everything yeah and so that was amazing
working there was absolutely incredible
and then working at so Mac was more
about artistry for me it was like
learning how to be a better makeup
artist so I feel like I got like the
best of both worlds that's cool did you
have any bizarre customer experiences I
did have oh my gosh
like it's pulling back okay I did weird
customer experience once at Sephora
uh-huh oh my god is so we like it I
haven't thought about this in so long
he's like six years but uh I'm most like
seven years but um I we're at the store
and he were like in the fragrances and
like this older man came up to me he was
like super tall he's like six four like
huge guy just like looking down I mean
he's like so like you work here and I'm
like fully glam like obviously I work
here and he's like yeah and he's like
yeah you know my wife's like shopping
around like and I was like oh cool cool
like you know very just casual
conversation he's like what are you
doing after and like fully like was like
I was like oh I'm going home like
thinking like I let him also like 21
like 22 oh and he's like 45 which is
fine not mine but like but like it was
just like a big difference like it was a
large difference between us and
like oh my god this is so weird cuz he
was like oh yeah you know my wife is
like were shopping around and I was like
uh-uh we're doing after I'm like oh uh
you know I'm going home
and I was like not into it at all and he
was like oh um maybe I can't like wait
for you after if you're down and I was
like I am what and so I literally was
like I Elise like got so dumped out in
this truck I didn't know what to do and
I was like you know I'm I'm I'm busy
sadly and until that thing is that was
really really weird is that when I told
him that I left because I was felt so
uncomfortable so awkward and it's
staying in the Sephora for literally
like like 10 minutes just like looking
at me like walking around like startling
yes and so I felt so much doesn't matter
I'm like I feel really uncomfortable
like I'm like scared he didn't like
attacked me after I get off work like
lingering and like what could I work in
a Sephora and he's huge yeah I was like
how am I got this [ __ ] off like skinny
I was skinny and like now working out
like didn't know what to do so I was
like okay can I get like security like
after like I didn't and so luckily like
I didn't see him after but it was just
really weird like he was like lingering
around like Gary awhile and the things I
work in Sephora inside JCPenney so they
kick it like he was like walking around
JCPenney
like he wasn't like leaving he would
just like look and like look into
Sephora to see if I was still there and
then he would walk away it was ever
confirmed that he had a wife that was no
I think no I have no idea like I never I
feel like that - I'm just saying that
because like hey I'm gonna be into it
like I won't [ __ ] it was really really
really weird creepy yeah I was super
cute I like a story time money on my
channel I just can't remember it like
fully the story in the house was so long
ago yeah I talked about it and I was
like this is like crazy very scary why
is this happening to me magnetizing
these random s weird shits like
literally it happens to be all time I
have the weirdest [ __ ] stories did
you ever see that guy again
no I didn't you never saw after like
after he was like he just seemed so
weird and like off and I was able to
confront Lee it was just a really weird
experience
yeah direct yeah not see me after sorry
thank you so much
peruse the JCPenney yes no one just
going to the bedding section seems like
it's not happening oh wow you've been
through it I've been through the wringer
wait so how long did you work at Sephora
or you worked there for a couple months
then how long did you work at Mac for I
worked at yeah I worked at soar for for
a year and I worked at Mac for like
maybe nine months almost like yeah I was
like what do you have both of them okay
and it was around then that you started
making videos right so actually I was at
Sephora still when I would had an
Instagram so I was like guys before I
went on Instagram and I it was at the
end of my Sephora journey when I started
an Instagram on social media and then it
was going into Mac and like the me
basically the makeup that I was wearing
at Mac I would just put it on Instagram
and that was always social media part
for my head at the time I was like oh
like this is really fun it's cute like I
get a post to makeup that I'm wearing to
work online cuz I was already wearing it
so might as well like you know his photo
ahead and see any other boy is really as
many other boys like wearing especially
with like facial hair and things like
that so I'm like you know I I thought
about doggedness boys that were like you
know looking like shaving their face
doing the whole thing you know I wanted
to do something a little bit different
so that's kind of why I started it and
then it was a couple months into working
him act I was like I'm gonna start a
YouTube channel and that's like when I
started my channel working a Mac oh very
cool hmm but before all this I you went
you were going to pursue medical school
I was you ready to be a plastic surgeon
really mm-hmm
you know like how the where the [ __ ]
that I actually had always been into
plastic surgery like my whole entire
life I always just loved it like I loved
you how did that start I don't know I
mean I was watching nip/tuck I don't
know like god damn it was so I can't
right yeah but I was really I think I
was just really fascinated with the fact
that like if people had the option to
shoot something they could and that they
wanted to like up there and to care
about something that you could change it
and there's nothing wrong with that it's
later be like well I don't like that
well I want to be able to change and
like take control of your own self and
do it if you want
yeah and I've always loved that and you
know and I think that the reason I got
so much into makeup is cuz it's almost
like that in a way it's like almost like
a mini form of plastic surgery yeah it's
like you
enhancing certain things and D enhancing
certain things and I really really
really loved that aspect of it so I was
going to school full-time while I was a
waiter and it's a four-hour Mac and when
I graduated I was like between like
graduating college and getting my
bachelor's degree and then going into
like you know furthering my school hmm
but I was like I found makeup like in
that little sweet spot between the two
and so that's kind of where I like
ventured off to wasn't I was like okay
whoa I'm working at Mac I'm starting a
YouTube channel like I should be looking
at [ __ ] med schools but I'm not this
is so much more fun like I was so over
school like [ __ ] I've been here five
years I'm from LA I had such senioritis
and I was like I really don't want to
keep going to school but I still had a
passion for it you know and so I found
this passion and makeup as like a mini
for plastic surgery and a lot faster I
was like you know what I'm just gonna do
this instead and luckily like because I
was so passionate about it I feel like
it really took off would you ever go
back to school do not miss a days where
I'm like freaking a host at the waiter
stand like looking over flashcards but
I'm like people and I'm like just trying
to study like I just I'm over it I'm
over school Oh games over it that's I
mean there's so many youtubers that
haven't even done like college know
right now right you've already I have
that higher education and right now hmm
I feel better that I feel like I have a
bachelor's degree so I'm like yeah and
science I can help science that's
amazing um do you are you able to spot
plastic surgery really well no just
because you were fascinated by it
it depends like how good that's like the
surgery was like if it's not really if
it's a really really good surgery like
you should not be able to clock it right
well you should be like oh you think I
would have never guessed you know but if
it's like I can always of course tell
like a bad situation or someone that's
not as well done yeah definitely and I
think it's also because I like what I do
with makeup like I'm a really good
honing in on the face like makeup wise
and so I think that I kind of just
translate to it like the surgery in the
makeup like I'm so like honed in on
people's faces that makes sense
do you watch botched and that kind of
I've seen it uh-huh uh-huh I can't thank
too much I get so overwhelmed I'm like
I'm so sorry that your ass went from
round to flat it just doesn't make sense
when the freakin [ __ ] flips over and
you're like oh it's flat
and I'm like I'm so sorry yeah I have to
draw the line mm-hmm okay escape the
night oh my god how was that oh my god
it was so much fun it looks like it's so
much fun we had Joey and Daniel on a few
months ago and I didn't even realize
that it's it's so not like really
scripted right no it's like literally
not at all yeah I had no idea I was
watching it and I was like because I
really didn't understand the concept if
I thought it was like murder mystery or
something and then I watched him a bit
now it's like oh it's escape rooms
mm-hmm but wait like survivor yeah yes
clue yeah like it's literally like such
a it's a very so how is that for you
it was super fun actually had a lot of
fun doing it it was hard filming super
early because literally like you start
you like get into your chair like for
like night shoots Nitra so we like start
shooting at 8:00 we don't wrap to like
three or four in the morning
Wow and so it's like oh my god like four
and I was like for a week straight
because I like lasted pretty long in my
season so I'm like I am so dead tired
after like the fifth day of shooting
you're like yeah like like [ __ ] your
bones are chattering
you just can't do it so anyways
youtubers so everyone has their own
whole like empires that they're running
in the back I think it's like week off
literally you know to be able to do this
and also like be very inconspicuous you
can't like snap that you're there doing
anything they're just kind of like hey
guys just having a great day today go
away for literally twelve hours like
yeah I was crazy but it was so much fun
cause it was just nice to be around like
all the youtubers and just everyone and
everyone's so sweet and you know I love
Joey and Daniel so much and I had such a
fun time doing it that's awesome
yeah what's it like doing how much
guidance do they give you you they just
say like here's where you're gonna be
and then we need you to run there and
then oh not even like not even at
literally be like okay like we're on a
row and they're like okay um wait five
minutes I'm like okay and like something
will happen and we just have to kind of
go from there and like we all just kind
of to figure it out like it's like the
fun part about it
that's very we would have to like figure
it out everything like it was like
something happened like Oh something
crash we'd all run outside like we were
just instinctively do whatever we wanted
to do which what I liked it so much
because it wasn't like super planned
yeah and it's not scripted like all the
things I said and like I just said them
cuz I wanted to say it same with
everyone else so it's like you'd hear
huge crash we would run outside like
what is this what we have to do and we
try to figure it out and then we'd go
from there and if and if when like we
all had to split up that is what maybe
okay like you got like this these people
are going there these people are going
there okay and that's like and then we
have to figured out ourselves again so
like that would they don't really guide
us very much that's what I liked about
it because it was such a fun like
interactive experience and you're I mean
you're in the moment so much yes because
you you have to be right like this
scares are real like we're screaming
it's real like I'm literally like if
something like what happened like I'm
and I scream like I'm really like
literally screaming yeah out of fear I
feel like that's how you get the most
authentic reactions from youtubers and
they wanna be and it honest it just
works out I feel like it makes it more
fun yeah YouTube's gonna bring their own
link personality to it yeah then you
don't have to overthink it too much
you're really just reacting yeah if I
can YouTube react would you do it again
I would do it again yeah actually what I
think I just think it's a it's of fun
and it's fun doing with everyone else
and it's kind of fun to kind of play on
a character when you're in it yeah cuz
you're still you're but you're playing a
character so it's like okay we just be
more [ __ ] today just like a little bit
more let me just like you know let me
just put my little acting pencil just
like let me just today let me be so
sweet today I think one of the best
parts of the show is the Wardrobe oh my
god it's the best yeah it's bad they
kill it and like just everything that
they do it just it's such a good show
like like it's just so thought-out and
it's so just well done like very smart
hmm it's very calm and it's fun it's fun
to kind of use your brain but also like
personality there's so much like
involved with it were there any mishaps
I mean I'm sure it's all such a blur to
okay cuz I clearly like it's like even
there's like days worth like you'd film
two episodes a night so it's literally
like white like we even know what day
you know I was like what was this like I
you know everything blurs together but
you don't for the most part like the
teams are so good like there's no
mishaps like they were happening on sale
like everything was just that flowed
really easily that's great
okay we're gonna take a quick break when
we get back I have a bunch more
questions for you and then the
Internet's got some questions we right
back with more - is the newest and most
affordable online where and return a
rental subscription for everyday
clothing you have the clothes you have
the staples of your wardrobe that you've
invested in and then there's the clothes
that add a - you see where I'm going of
color print fashion or trend to your
wardrobe these are the pieces that you
rent with hammer - fall in love with
getting dressed up again
with an endless rotation of clothes you
simply fill your virtual closet with
everything you want to wear have fun
with new trends experiment with things
you would normally shy away from you get
three items shipped at a time and then
wear them once or as often as you want
when you send back all three items you
get your next shipment of three and you
can swap your items for new ones as
often as you want per month and if you
fall in love with something you can buy
it for a discounted price and you get
all of this for just $59 a month this
sounds pretty perfect you get to do it
all in the comfort of your own home in
the comfort of the glow of your own
laptop you know hi I'm onboard
so head over to have er - comm and sign
up today there are no commitments and
you can cancel anytime that's havre - h
AV e r da sh comm okay your father is
extremely supportive he gets so
supportive of you and this like a
non-traditional career path right um you
know is actually really crazy community
to have such a long long long long
history you know like in the beginning
it wasn't as supportive and it wasn't as
like what it was it was very
understanding like neither of us really
tried to understand one another mm-hmm
and so I was like okay um hmm so we
didn't have a really good relationship
for a big part of our life and just cuz
you didn't want to try we were both
confused and we were just like we
really know what to do sure with one
another because of like he wanted me to
be you know I wanted to play he wanted
me to play sports and be like you know
like my little brothers and I was like
well I'm so not like that I want to do
Ellen thing and you know I'd understand
him he'd understand me and so just like
battle all the time we had to deal with
and so I feel like as time progressed he
started and I started to grow up I
started to be more open myself and not
be so closed off I think that as he grew
as he grew and like learned as well it
just kind of like we just started to
like mesh more yeah we're understanding
it's like you know when you like the kid
just like don't understand you're like
you're like you're like forget my
parents like they're so annoying they
don't understand me right now it's very
that and so like as I started getting
older
it started becoming more and more
accepted with us that we both started
accepting each other more and so it was
really really hard like even when I was
like 21 mm-hmm like it was still really
really hard and I think that once I
start to get on social media and I would
show my parents like the messages I
would be getting from people and just
like how I've helped him in some way
yeah I think they both are very like
taken aback and shocked at the fact that
like impact what it is like the impact
that I've had on people and by just
being my authentic self and they're like
oh my god like this is crazy and like my
dad especially like as being someone
that wasn't as accepting for him to be
like doing a full 180 you know he also
went to therapy and he did so many
things that he really wanted to
understand me he wanted to work he put
in the work yeah and I think that that's
a huge part of it like you have to put
in the work and you have to try and same
with me I put in the work for him and I
think we got to such a great spot now
where it's literally like he would do
anything for me and he's so supportive
of everything that I do and he's like my
biggest fan that's so sweet didn't
VidCon this year no no no yes he did
answer that yeah okay what do you think
of it he knows crazy he just I was like
the craziest big experience like this is
so nuts he's not like other conventions
with me he's gone to like beautycon with
me and yeah it's like my mom and him and
my brother like I have such a like
close-knit family who are so supportive
and they'll always like come and support
me yeah so I've been really really
really lucky with that that's incredible
he doesn't have his own channel though
he does have his own channel he does
yes what did he post on his own I mean
he's like posted like one bit
and like oh my god you're so cute like
just like do your thing but he it's cuz
we you know we made a video together
back in the day I was last year and it
was about you know just like the
struggles that we both kind of face
together and just like talking about our
journey and um you know made it such an
impact on people that he was like I want
to create a channel and like just talked
like me parents about like their kids
the del GBD kids and I think that that
was a big part for him he wants to like
you know feel like he was part of it he
wanted to feel like he was really really
helping and that's so sweet
what I what a huge like pivot it's like
crazy cuz that you have family like tell
us like how crazy it is that how much my
dad has changed cuz I can't that's how
he wasn't like that before right like
wow like what a huge difference at
cousins of his and things like that and
like it's it's so crazy I'm so lucky to
have like a dad who was gone a full 180
and is so supportive and understanding
of me know for as where I was like back
in the day he was like dill your
Instagram and I was like fight them on
things and so I just like it kind of
adds like to the story and I'm like dad
I'm like really proud of you because it
was so hard in the beginning and now
where it is it's like it makes it such a
full-circle link moment and it makes it
you know so much easier for you as a
creative and like exciting for you as a
kind of knowing that you have that
support behind you absolutely yeah I'm
not feeling like you're disgracing
someone or maybe someone uncomfortable
being yourself mm-hmm
speaking of like doing cool things lunar
beauty yeah okay how did this come to be
yeah so lunar Beauty that's my brand and
I I've been wanting to have a brand for
years and you know as soon like when I
was even in the beauty space and I was
you know playing with makeup and
reviewing makeup and like it was like
things that I was like why I feel like
this is missing this and I'd always like
in my mind like envision something like
in front of me where I was like why I
feel like I would have changed
assistants this yeah like I was just
done like these little things and I'll
just weekend I feel like well if I'm
doing this like why can't I just do
myself and we create the products that
I'm like envisioning or create like I
feel like for me what was missing was
like an aesthetic of a brand like a very
fun
gray packaged great quality you know
and I was like I really wanted to do
this so I started working on Luna beauty
like oh my gosh like three four years
ago yeah mm-hmm I start working a very
long time ago with my parents and they
were so supportive me my dad and my mom
both work with the new beauty and I in
like they're like my full-time
supporters and they also work with the
brand so it's like they're literally
like in its family it's a family
business family affair
so for me was just it was really just a
passion of mine and I'm like I'm
literally wearing makeup for a living
like why would I not create products I
truly love it's like I review things I
know what I like and I feel like if
people trust my opinion on my reviews
then I felt they would trust my opinion
on products like create and I luckily
I've been so lucky in I've come out with
great products and people have been
really loving them they reviewed me
amazingly yeah thing I mean I give you
guys so much credit in the beauty world
because the idea of creating like let me
create a lipstick seems basic enough
some right enough but like the actual
process of doing that and then the
audience like acceptance of that has
such high stakes and high risk that it
blows my mind what happens sometimes and
like poof I could never know it's crazy
baddam that's going into like creating
products in that sort of world like what
are your sort of like standards and
practices for that like do you I'm sure
you're like super anal about the things
that you want for your for lunar so like
what uh what what kind of like take us
through like how you brainstorm for our
product I feel like for me like how
inspiration hits me it's like such a
weird way sometimes like I'll just be
looking at something and I'm like oh my
gosh I'm an idea and I can't like write
down my notes and then are like at night
time like I'm much more of a nighttime
person than a daytime person so a lot of
times I call it create like literally
vide like I literally like will create a
full like palette or something like in
the middle of like out like the last
path I created or one that I'm working
on for next year it's like it was like
1:00 in the morning and I had tons of
shades around me and I started putting
together and I was like so on like I was
just I was on a good way [ __ ] good
way okay ever since I created so it was
like a little late at night and like
that's just when it hits me and I feel
like for me it's not about like trend
it's not about like you know trying to
hit the like mark in that way for me
it's about like creating products I
truly love and I feel like other people
would love as well so I'm not really
trying to trace a trend I'm just like
creating things that I'm truly inspired
by and things that I saw in the store I
would purchase a myself that is like
what I think about with my brand like I
want to be heavy feeling I want to feel
like I wanted people to be able to tell
that I worked so hard on it yeah and I
feel like with the things that I have
you can and that's like that was the
whole point for me really okay
what um are there any what's like your
number one Holy Grail product right now
hmm I was like it's such a hard question
because I feel like that there's also
like different spots of the face like
Holy Grail for different things sure so
it's like I guess Holy Grail forever
would be like concealer cuz I can see
there's like the easiest thing to like
you know under your eyes yeah spot
concealer just makes you feel better
when you're wearing can see there
sometimes so I would say that Holy Grail
in general would be concealer or like
lip balm would even like two things um
but you know product wise the most fun
and like palettes and yeah I shadow and
things like that so you just you kind of
you hinted that you're working on
something for next year mm hmm hmm is
that the faces of launches like year by
year or season by season
it's like um it depends on every brand
like which is you know it's different
for everyone but for me like when I
started concept for something I usually
take about him a year in someone's to
like come out with it yeah it's like I
start mining like concept and then like
won't come out to like a year and some
change after that and I'm like okay I
was out like now I know I think it's so
long that's what I came up with that was
a hard night for me that day like [ __ ]
like that's I completely agree with you
and that's it's crazy cuz you like not
only that it's like when you come out
then your product you're like already
thinking about your next like two
launches and you're like oh my god like
I need to focus on this one product I
just launched tell it like that deserves
its own love but you're also thinking so
far ahead and that's kind of how it is
when you own a brand dang are you guys
are you venturing out into things
outside of makeup I'm right now we're
just just make up being I think I'm just
going to venture into doing more
categories of the face so it's like
right now I have
lit liquid lipsticks glosses eyeshadows
and highlighters and so now I'm working
on you know like doing things like
blushes and you know other different
ventures and other spots of the face I
want to like work on very cool very cool
yeah um you have a beautiful dog
thank you how she's got groomed
yesterday's looks how old is she she's
like oh my gosh she's gonna be 3 in
December she's so freaking cute the
cutest when where did you get her so
actually a really crazy story so I was
in Aspen Colorado so I was in like Aspen
Colorado in like a couple years ago um
with a brand and I was I got an email
from these this like person that was
like oh like you know our dog had a
litter of puppies um we would think that
like she's so cute we think you would
like be interested in she sent me two
photos of it and I was like okay and
they're like if you want one like we
wouldn't absolutely love to send you the
person you knew no was like okay cool
that's what I was there I was like
there's no freaking way in hell I can
handle like having a dog because like my
life was so crazy I'm like no I can't
like I travel too much it's not
responsible with me but luckily have my
brother lives with me so I'm like well
you know if I'm gone he'll stay home
she'll be fine
you know but I was like no I can't do it
I can't do it but then I saw the photo
of her and I was like oh my god I'm
cracked like an egg this is so
impossible he coming not gonna have her
so that I was like okay okay she loves
it know what her name was a right away
like it wasn't even like I change it to
say like they're like we have zaiah here
and I was like I really like that name
too like it was like aw like the stars
were aligning for me and she was you
know hyper allergenic I kinda want a dog
that shedded right you know and so
things like that's something okay well
I'm gonna yeah I would absolutely like
love one of them and literally within
like three days like they flew her over
to me yeah I still am stuck on this is a
random person that you know it wasn't
like a dog it's like a dog company like
oh we have like you know we have dogs
here in the hairs want to know if you
were like down doodles they specifically
had doodles doodles
yeah she's a doodle she's like a toy
doodle it sounds like okay
and so they flew her out to me I so
remember like getting her like the Delta
terminal and I was like what this is
crazy
yeah she's like in her little crate I
got it I saw it I saw her she was
smaller than I thought she was in me she
was literally like a pound she was so
tiny and so I remember when I got to my
car and she was in the crate like I
opened it and just I wanted to like hold
her she was like crazy she was licking
me she like ride away she was upset she
peed all over me laughing I was like I
was like not even discussed I was like
she just peed all over me I guess this
is really real so it was it was like
love before science I brought her home
and you know had like I was like trying
like potty trained her how her little
peepee pad and stuff like that so it was
a love at first sight sure does she
travel with you no she does I'm actually
not a huge like I don't like the idea of
like traveling with her as much because
I don't want her to get stressed out
yeah she's also like so small yes and it
would make me stress if I like left in a
hotel room yeah I'm like out doing
something and like I the whole idea of
it really freaks me out yeah so I'm like
no I can't like own her stay home feel
comfortable or like I would take her my
parents house they have dogs too and
something sugar to run around play with
them
I'd rather um her feel comfortable at
home and not be like flying with me to
New York yeah you know yeah yeah even
though I miss her I'd rather her feel
more comfortable oh that's a good dog
dad good daddy is she is she well
behaved is she good she's a [ __ ] she
honestly is she's definitely a pain a
yes and I I'm like wow you really take
after me the girl shocking the Apple did
not fall far from the tree
no but she is because she she has her
moments like she is well behaved yeah
this is also like she'd love to throw
tantrums like it's her favorite thing to
do I literally like to be eating
something and if she's next to me should
be looking at me and I'm like you can't
have Annie she'll like all right and she
starts like bark at me like as if like
I'm telling her no she starts like dig
around me and she like those are like a
head bag like she literally throws a
human tantrum I don't like what is wrong
with you like crazy
yeah like if I'm gone for too long out
of town she like [ __ ] on my bed and I'm
like we talked about
like wow like so she like she deftly has
an attitude but it makes it like so much
more fun because she's so made it and
some little edges is so funny
like if someone gives me like if I'm
filming in my beauty room and she's in
the room with me and if someone comes in
and wants to talk to me like she just
goes off on them which is like he's
literally like don't disturb him
it's really weird and I'm like never
understand how like you're psychotic
yeah she's very protective very bossy
but I think it just makes it more fun
cuz she's so little and she was like a
bunch of pounds I'd be like [ __ ] you
need to go to [ __ ] counseling yeah
but because she's like 4 pounds I'm like
you know what I can handle yeah let it
happen cuz it's kind of killed it's so
sweet ok you in the beauty makeup world
PR packages are given letting crazy
right I remember when this first started
happening like years ago and it was like
oh my god that's so cool for you guys I
wish we had that in the other world of
you yes yes for anything but also how
can we get in on that and now it's
gotten to like such an insane degree I
feel like like what's the craziest like
PR package that you've gotten I mean
I've gotten really intense packages I've
gotten a package one so it was like a
sailboat well it's like a human sized
little boat oh wait what what actual
[ __ ] like a raft it was a wooden bamboo
raft human sized raft and like it was
like a life-size of me on it and I was
like [ __ ] am I gonna do with this get
this [ __ ] out of my house
it was a PR packet is let me just like I
was just like here's our bronzer so why
the [ __ ] are you actually gonna boat
with it it was very weird it's like a
naked and afraid raft it was it was
literally psychotic and they were like
as of you like it would tie coconuts to
the side it was one of those kind of
weird rafts that was very passed away
but I was like okay like this is really
I had like human sized paintings of
yourself of myself
had vacuum cleaners like really weird
ass [ __ ] that you're like why is your
with me right now really really really
really weird but I think I think they're
really like I think they're fun like
when it's like that were like this is
who thinks of this like so it's either
this so upset I've had it word really I
want to go pick up packages one day the
next day I'm gonna pick up packages and
at eight more packages that day and I'm
like this is like getting crazy yeah
that's I mean it's now become comical
how many PR packages I see get opened up
on Instagram oh it's right it's
literally funny let me get like like 20
a week who are your like favorite people
to follow online like for better or
worse like on Instagram like I love me
some Britney Spears on Institute it for
her I just want to check in and make
sure she's okay yeah no no I love
following like RuPaul's Drag Race
like girls those are those like that's
like am I like being around my guys love
what like seeing the girls that's he's
in a drag race think I'll follow them oh
yeah wow just to see like how they're
doing like I just think it's really
that's like my like little like guilty
pleasure is watching like drag race and
then following all the girls for me and
I'm like okay like how are you guys
doing I mean I like I like I mean I love
drag race so I thought it was really fun
I thought was great to watch
yeah did you watch it I did I did what
did you think I liked it I thought it
was really good I think EVs is really is
great I love her I think she's super
cool I love Brooklyn
I know Brooklyn is just so like eloquent
like elegant elegant yeah she's so good
I did think the final lip-sync was a
little like underwhelming mm-hmm that
something more was gonna happen yeah I
was waiting for like something really
crazy reveal v's big dresses like
something's under there there's gonna be
two more like her like head was in like
a rotate 360 link Brandi
like would you ever do drag race like be
in it mm-hmm no would you ever judge
drag race absolutely I would love to be
like a mini-challenge like I'm gonna get
like I'm just like a hey like this like
a social medium like mini-challenge I'd
be so down for that like that's
something I know what to do I feel like
that's the easiest insert for make up
for sure I mean I mean it may have like
you don't wanna Stassi about me Hills is
like their sponsor right I could be so
much fun to just kind of go in and just
like hang out with the girls like a
little mini challenge I just wanna go
behind that two-way mirror now oh my god
me too but now they all know that it's
to a I know but still I wouldn't
absolutely love it I just seem like it
seems like such a fun show to be part of
it yeah I really want to do it I feel
like the like even like the crew would
be having a great time yeah they all
just seem cool I see them all like what
I've gone to like the finale tapings
like the past couple years and there's
so fun all you see all the crew and it's
just like such a fun crazy experience
that's every pause even more gorgeous in
real life yeah what else do you watch or
are you watching ooh
euphoria just ended which I'm so
devastated because I love that show is
so good I loved everything about that
show it to be honest I thought the way
it was shot I love the characters I
loved the acting and everything about it
it was so cool seeing a show talk about
like you know real life situations a
real life you know struggles that teens
go through and adolescent she's really
great it's really good you have to watch
it it's really really good I loved
watching the show pose um I loved
watching I really into the boys right
now I just I just finished no way I'm
like two episodes way from finishing I
won't tell you anything but yeah it was
that show I came like my boyfriend are
watching and I just kept screaming like
I literally cannot predict what's going
to handle that same in this show me see
overwhelmed the plane scene yeah
well no the first I want to die well
that we just turned it on and all of a
sudden like we just see it like a butt
and I was like yes well what is this
[ __ ] I was so into it absolutely a male
but I love and I love seeing a little
tan line with the white is so cute to me
something sexy about like a tan line ya
know the boys is really so good it's on
Amazon if anyone is curious and it is
like don't get too high when you watch
it though because then it gets real
scary no it's crazy it's literally like
it's like a superhero show but it's like
dark yeah and all of a sudden like
things get gory for a long time and
you're like what but it's also kind of
funny sometimes yeah it's good it's got
something for everything okay we're
gonna take one last break we have a
bunch of Twitter questions to get to so
we'll be right back with more nacho deep
perfect
[Music]
there is something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help online
counseling can help they offer licensed
professional counselors who specialize
in issues like depression anxiety
relationships trauma anger family
conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment you can get
help at your own time at your own pace
anything you share is confidential and
it's so convenient you can schedule
secure video or phone sessions as well
as chat and text with your therapist and
if for some reason you're not happy with
your counselor they can get you a new
one you can request a new one at anytime
for no additional charge and best of all
it's affordable and you beautiful
listeners get 10% off your first month
with the discount code grace so get
started by going to better help calm
slash grace then fill out a
questionnaire to help them assess your
needs and get you matched with a
counselor that you'll love that's better
help calm slash grace okay Manny we're
gonna get into Twitter questions but
right before we do I'm going to ask you
the two questions that I ask every
single guest that's on the podcast hmm
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most want to throw cold spaghetti at
oh my god oh my god that's because it
would like stick to them I guess
potentially unless there
really lotioned up huh who would I throw
cold spaghetti in it I oh my god I don't
it can be good it can be bad in the fun
way you can it's your intention behind
the course you know what okay so it
would be I would probably throw cold
spaghetti and like a food fight
situation and Lady Gaga if like she
would like throw it back and they'd be
fun oh yeah it would be like a fun
experience like very like I would all
right shoot yeah I should make it artsy
and very cool and like very fun I think
that and it would be like in a good way
not unlike a your [ __ ] here's some
spaghetti oh my god let's have a food
fight
yeah that's a big guys just like love
her okay the other question is to tell
us your worst pants shooting story
we're hosts call but you can only tell
us in three words or three small phrases
so for example mine is college jogging
front lawn okay high school bus
volleyball game okay let's get into
these Twitter questions
Twitter affect someone's know what's a
good inexpensive eyeshadow palette
preferably one with a really good yellow
shade I was like I like expensive and
inexpensive or like that's objective
yeah because I think inexpensive yeah it
could mean a lot of different things
is it depend cuz I don't necessarily
think some of the palette set like
Sephora are expensive but other people
might think that they're very expensive
totally um let's say let's say I would
say probably like with a good like
yellow and it would probably end up
being something like um we make a more
fee like nine
penpal it wears like a small palette but
just like all bright colors and it's the
kinda like a strong yellow in it do they
have like good pigmented like mattes yes
I feel like mm-hmm cheap I don't know
much about makeup but I feel like those
yellow colors if you go to a drugstore
you're never gonna find one that's like
pigmented enough yeah yeah it was
actually one of the hardest shades of
create a be yellow and one of my
palettes and life's a drag and it was it
was probably like one of my most [ __ ]
of a shades to create really mm-hmm
it's so hard but would you do it again
yeah so exactly I love it I think it's
like I love the shade yellow to wear
yeah yeah oh that's great okay someone
says grace please ask him why he is so
high-maintenance love dad so I believe
this is from Annie's senior I was like
dad first of all the hard thing is I
have a heart I don't know how to
fact-check his like it says Manny's
senior ex's name they literally hit that
was living him but I don't know if
that's like a fan writing Manny's senior
and he's pretending to be your daddy you
know mom and dad is there ever a time
because your dad is active on Twitter
hmm
that you have to like mute him or like
I've absolutely meet him that's him and
be like you have to delete that
absolutely like dad let's calm it down
okay deep breath and let's go ahead and
mute Twitter for a little bit oh no but
he's like he's such a trooper he like
cracks me up on Twitter so I'm like I
just let him do whatever he wants to do
oh that's real sweet okay someone wants
to know if he could do anyone's makeup
alive or dead who would he choose I
think I don't want to Beyonce's makeup
where's it gonna be so sickening I think
I really do let's turn her out do you
know what kind of makeup you would do on
her I wanna just do like a really pretty
like bronzy look like yeah oh she
already goes with but I just want to see
like how I could do it and just like
kind of just being like that close to
proximity I think would be like it yeah
I'd be like oh my [ __ ] I'm touching her
face I feel like I've never washed my
hands again like it was literally it be
that I really have to wash your hands
like at least 40 times before you say
between sanitizing like that is so so
much fun oh my gosh uh-oh
someone says do you wish that you had a
chance to be on escape tonight all-stars
um I do only cuz I feel like it'd be I
had so much fun the first time yeah and
so I would have left a bit on I see it
the night the all-star season but I was
really really busy during the time that
they were shooting something it's okay
you are I mean you and you had the
experience and I already had the
experience you know and I thought it was
so so so much fun some that's great
has he tried the popeyes chicken
sandwich I'm not it is a good I don't
know I've never even heard of that is
this a thing for you like do you like
Popeyes Chicken I learned about inside
jokes like they have based on the
questions that people ask me like ask
him about blah blah blah and it'll be
like I have no idea but they'll know
yeah so this is not something in your
insider and the answer is no he hasn't
tried okay so thank you for the question
faux Shasta Jones I do want some [ __ ]
funny chicken right now oh okay now
yesterday it came out yesterday
oh so it's a big big just global
tripping Wendy's coming back with their
like McNuggets and [ __ ] oh yeah yeah um
can you do my makeup before a date that
I have yet to schedule from Lily Marston
absolutely I would love to that's really
funny cuz I do get asked all the time
like emailed like about doing people's
makeup and I'm like do you really and I
feel bad cuz I'm actually really really
busy and I feel so guilty if I had a
cancel because I'm like yeah do you want
to do something do you do private
appointments or anything like that like
do you do people's like makeup for
special occasions or anything no I've
actually done like unless it's a collab
with someone I haven't done someone's
makeup and like or like if it was like
my mom like other than that having done
five years and years and years oh wow
yeah because it's just like it's been
you're busy I'm busy
yeah very busy uh do you think 2019 is
treating you well by the way I love you
I do think that design teens train you
I've actually been I fight this like one
of my most happy I've ever been yeah on
YouTube and things like that I feel like
I really just kind of honed in on like
what I enjoy and things that I'm happy
with and things that I like and yeah not
really focusing on myself and I feel
like it's been really nice I've actually
really really enjoyed chosen 19 that's
great yeah how have you I mean cuz how
long have you been on YouTube now like
five years six years five years yeah
five years have you felt like the itch
or the burnout or any of that sort of
I'm definitely no I definitely
definitely do there's definitely moment
so I'm like dude I can't [ __ ] do this
like I cannot keep doing this it's just
it seems like it's so hard sometimes
like I'm like I feel burnt out and I
don't want to do this I want take a
break and you know but I feel like when
you take a break then it like you get
like your momentum momentum like dies
down and the algorithm like doesn't want
to [ __ ] with you anymore and there's so
many different things that I'm like well
I had to kind of have to keep going yeah
what do you do - like generate ideas and
that sort of thing I feel like in beauty
it's I'm really lucky in the way that
there's always new product coming out
and there's always things to review and
there's always things that people want
to like know about that are just being
released and I think that that really
really helps in the beauty world because
there's always new makeup and there's
always like something fun to do is
always like let's go to Target and get
some makeup in just like things like
that I feel like really really lucky in
that sense but then I also feel like
well sometimes I don't you want to do a
beauty video or just like sit back and
like tell the gym story yeah you know
it's like I feel like you kind of have
to switch it up yeah were there any
Beauty like challenges or trends that
you were like I'm not doing that
there's a lot that I didn't do I was
like I'm literally not [ __ ] doing
this like cardiac I don't think I could
do like the hundred layers of nail
polish I there's no idea yeah yeah
there's no way I could do like just like
challenges like that where I was like I
can't anybody can't do this yeah I don't
have the patience for that something I
just don't like I want to get in film
and get out yeah and like I can't just
sit there for like eight hours and just
do know something I mean crazy
Oh someone's no how does he keep up with
all of the new makeup launches I don't
quite honest now honestly there's so
many makeup there's so much makeup
that's released nowadays yeah and it
honestly gets really really really
overwhelming for me
so now cuz like I get like you know most
of it right I think for me it's like I
essentially want to use things and new
products from brands that are
I've been supportive of me in the past
and who are you know trying their best
to be inclusive and I want to work with
brands that are just really great yeah
and like if it's a brand that just wants
any product for the free promo then I'm
like okay well you know I'll do like a
snap or something but if I'm like really
wanting to like work with the brand or
give like props to a brand that I've
worked with or a brand that like really
tries their best to do the best that
they can then I'm more likely to use
like their new products just because I
feel like if they treat me well they
treat others well yeah then I I want to
give them more of a shout out that's
awesome is there any or are there any
brands that you look forward to the most
when they have new launches or even just
like a new product like that you're most
excited about honestly not really only
cuz now so many brands come out with so
many new things so often that it makes
me overwhelmed and I'm like the only
brand I'm like [ __ ] inner beauty
that's happens because it just it's hard
to keep up with so many different brands
yeah it's overwhelming just hearing
about mm-hmm someone know if there's one
thing that he could change in life or do
differently what would it be and why um
actually this question asked a lot
people always ask me like well if there
was like one thing you can do and I feel
like for me um I always end up saying
like there's not anything I really
changed I think it gets me to like where
you are in that and like where I am now
and I feel like I'm actually like one of
the happiest I've ever been in my whole
life and I feel like I've learned so
much yeah in the past few years that
it's like I don't think I would change
anything
you know um except like you learn like
you've learned such a valuable life
lessons yeah when you go through part
time and it's all part of it you know
it's all part of life and life's not
always easy all the time and you know
you kind of have to just be there for
the hard times I appreciate the good
times I feel like I always understand
like no I wouldn't change anything
that's great mm-hmm yeah coz how can you
possibly know what good feels like if
you haven't felt bad exactly exactly you
can't get to the rainbow without the
rain first hell yeah
on that prolific note here's a question
would you rather look like a potato or
feel like a potato [ __ ] harness
question I see a mic wait I know that
today I know like the appropriate
answers but I'd rather feel
like there is so good about themselves
you can do honestly would in a second
these beautifully packaged eyeshadow
palettes and then it would immediately
reach for them oh I love that okay if
you could run one business which would
it be and how would you change it oh my
gosh like I would run like Apple or like
something like on Amazon like I would be
like I want one run some like humongous
you won't want to run a huge Corp okay I
would run it until I can sell it there's
no me running it's just not gonna happen
I'm gonna need a cute little life from
there on in India they retire after that
acquisition thank you so much and I
would I mean I wouldn't change anything
I would just like change the ownership
maybe someone else how long did it take
you to feel successful oh my gosh that's
like it's such a great question cuz I
feel like success it's such an abstract
concept it really is and I feel like
it's actually the other day I heard this
like this quote about successfully
obviously can't rember right now but it
like hit me so hard and it was about
like how success is like what you may
give it and how you feel in
I truly think that's the absolute truth
cuz this moment so it's like you can
feel like you get millions of views of
millions of views of videos and hundreds
of thousand likes on aperture like
photos and like so many crazy things and
like you can still feel unsuccessful and
you're in your way but I feel like true
success comes from within and how you
feel about something so I feel like if
you're happy doing what you if you're
living the life that you want to live I
feel like you're successful yeah I think
that for me like that's what it is like
even if like things wane and you know
things like that I feel like success is
like on the inside and I really um I
really that's truly how I feel about it
I feel like the success is really what
you make of it
yeah and for me I feel like whenever
have people tell me in real life that
they you know watch my videos or that
they've changed in somewhere like
they've watched me when they were in the
hospital going through chemo and I feel
successful when people tell me that you
know and that's like when that's my
moment for success yeah that's beautiful
Thanks the alternative side someone to
know what's the worst part of his job
and they said but in a serious manner
not the stereotypical response what's
this he wrote a response for the worst
part was done I guess maybe the
stereotypical response is like negative
comments I think for me though one of
the hardest part is never being off yeah
that's like one of the hardest parts for
me is that I have a heart like
unplugging it's very hard when you're on
social media because on surge media like
it's like such a self driven job like
what we do it's self driven there's no
someone like telling us what to do you
know for us is like okay I need to film
and get this done like because we need
know we know we know that we need to do
it right not because someone's telling
us and someone's like making us do it
the thing that the hard part is
unplugging and unwinding and you know
taking time for yourself and like also
like when you're going out and like I've
been on dates and have someone come up
to me recognize me and I'm like oh my
god like I actually didn't tell them
that it was a youtuber yeah I think
things like that it was like you have to
just kind of be prepared and be on and I
would never want to give someone a bad
experience out in real life so you
always just kind of to be like
psychologically aware or even when I'm
like out at the club and hanging with
friends I'm just more on I just feel
like more on because I feel like I'll
get videos on Twitter of people like
recording me at the club and like I see
you and I'm like huh like it like freaks
me out you know are this so I think that
that's our part I was like never really
feeling like you're off and like really
fully relaxed
and that's hard because then you get
stuck feeling like you can't have a bad
day right exactly especially putt like
publicly you can't just be that person
that you drive by like that girl was
crying on this right no right Madge
endure like getting Twitter if I can
mention Twitter moment man we crying on
the street what a loser like [ __ ] that
would be said like like people and
people the thing is like people also
don't see youtubers I feel like as
regular people right so I feel like that
makes it really really hard to it's like
they almost make it like we can't make
mistakes right
you know life is about mistakes and you
make mistakes to live your life so I
feel like that makes it really really
hard yeah this has been so fun there's
one last question before we wrap up corn
or green beans a real big one green
beans probably not a corn person things
are really weird okay like I love you
always like you're always like here's
like some part of my god how many people
are my parents are like corn psychos
like there's corn dude like I literally
tell me I don't want the damn corn de
and they're like you like corn I'm like
no I don't so let's all give you [ __ ]
corn AHA leg so fun where you go every
guest on the podcast for being here and
giving us either time gets a
personalized fortune cookie here's got a
little warped I love a warped cookie
open it of course oh my god oh my god I
ripped the thing in half with a screen
but it just folded okay let's see mmm oh
my god this is so long
this is an official plea for you it home
I got a hole give me one second this is
an official plea for unique to recreate
the Catalina vacation Backstreet Boys
lip-sync same outfits and all the people
deserve it
yeah who said this the fortune cookie
who wrote this the Portage's came with
you can you give us context so I posted
so funny I posted a video with my little
it's embarrassing video with my other
brother on my Instagram
because it was like me Nick and Aaron
doesn't me to the brothers and we're all
super young and Nick the middle one it
was so into Backstreet Boys he like
glitter he thought he was like Justin
Timberlake dead-ass thought he was and
so he would like and saying perform oh
my god seem like a boy girl a boy band
back in the day no that's Backstreet
Boys oh yeah I think was like the other
one yeah [ __ ] where's Nick - Nick Carter
wasn't mad [ __ ] but he got it so what so
and they think was the other boy band
and my brother would like perform like
the song he'd be like bad like you
Willie I did the whole the whole judge
another thing and so there's a video I'm
Nick doing it and an errand in the back
like dancing cuz he's like a baby with
diapers like walking around but then he
like walks over to turn off turn to the
next song and Nick like freaks out and
he's like oh my god area like get out of
here like I've tried it before I'm like
living as well fantasy and he like
screams it and then he screams and walks
away and the Aaron changes a song and
then it goes to pants to me and I'm like
like sorry dude I was so embarrassed I
must be not like a camera person where I
may be like mom like turn the camera to
Aaron like don't record me for me and
then she's like laughing cuz I'm like
the one that's like so shy
and I'm like performing and then I sit
down I'm a totally know and they don't
make you stop recording me so it's
literally like psychotic so just funny
that going from there to now where I'm
like like I record myself for a living
oh man if she only knew yeah and now my
brother's opposite they're like don't
record us and I'm like Manny where can
people find you and lunar beauty and all
of it if they don't know you can find me
on Manny mu a 73 on Instagram I'm on
YouTube and Twitter and then you lunar
beauty is just literally lunar beauty on
Instagram go check out everything he's
up yes all beautiful stuff we'll see you
guys next time on another episode of not
too deep goodbye
ie 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep with Christ
Arabic not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer
Melissa demons writing by Diane Kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music post-production sound by
Christopher Bell
[Music]